ix legislature of the European  Parliament has officially begun members  elected from a hundred and ninety  political parties across 28 member  states met for their first session in  Strasbourg the European Parliament  elected David Maria sir solely as its  president in a secret ballot for the  next two and a half years the house also  elected 14 vice presidents there are  seven political groups in the Parliament  including new parties renew Europe born  out of the old Aldi group and identity  and democracy the successor to the  Europe of Nations and Freedoms group 61%  of MEP s are new to the chamber  including more women than ever before  the youngest MEP is only 21 years old  while the oldest is 82 Parliament  decided on the composition of 22  committees and subcommittees the  committee's adopt reports and consult  experts on specialized topics ranging  from foreign policy to fisheries and  women's rights